there's a pretty awesome scene in the
fate of the Furious where Jason Statham
fights a bunch of armed mercenaries on
an airplane while holding an adorable
baby in a carrier
I've always wondered how babies end up
in situations like this
what kind of hoops you have to jump
through to cast babies in Hollywood you
baby you she busted besides babysitting
delivering newspapers and wreath making
show business is the only industry that
can legally employ children under the
age of 14 in fact they've been in movies
almost since the birth of cinema I hate
myself so much casting a baby isn't as
simple as casting a grownup actor though
for one they don't have to get their
shift at Starbucks covered to go to an
audition but mostly because there are
some special rules producers have to
follow when casting an infant for
example in California babies can only be
on set for two consecutive hours per day
with actual work not exceeding 20
minutes under any circumstances the
state's child labor laws also require
that babies be at least 15 days old to
be eligible for a work permit which is
good news for babies who can just chill
during their literal first days on earth
but not so good for productions that
have scenes with newborns because the
thing is if you've ever seen a baby
that's two weeks old you know that they
don't exactly look like a newborn
anymore in order to get past this hurdle
productions often try to cast preemies
who look newborn even when they're the
required minimum of 15 days old and in a
lot of places outside california that's
perfectly legal in 16 states there are
actually zero regulations regarding
minimum age for baby employment in films
and many other states have laws that are
pretty lacks in New Jersey for example a
month-old baby can work five hours a day
five days a week and in Louisiana they
can be employed 6 hours a day 6 days a
week that's more hours than I worked
when I bagged groceries after I
graduated college and no I do not want
to talk about it most states also do
nothing to protect the money that babies
make only a few places follow the Coogan
law which requires that child actors be
set up with a blocked trust account to
protect their earnings the law is named
after Jackie Coogan an early
twentieth-century child actor who is in
a number of Charlie Chaplin films
including the American classic the kid
as a child actor he reportedly earned as
much as four million dollars but his
parents squandered all his money by the
time he became
an adult because of his parents moms and
dads in these states are required to set
aside 15 percent of their minors income
in a Coogan account which the child can
access at the age of 18 shooting with
babies can be complicated but the film
industry has a way of working around it
I would say nineties and 95% of jobs for
babies and toddlers are exclusive to
twins and triplets because two babies
can play one character so there's two
advantages there number one you can have
them both come to set at the same time
so it's when a gets fussy that they can
call in twinbee and they can use the
baby's back and forth and the other
thing is sometimes production will split
their call times so they'll have one
baby come in let's say at 9:00 in the
morning have another baby come in at
2:00 in the afternoon and so it extends
their day also half of all twins and
almost all triplets are born premature
so productions get more working hours
and they look newborn Sean Penn had a
different solution he directed a movie
that nobody saw called the last face
where they put out a casting call for a
one day old baby since they were
shooting in South Africa where you can
cast minors with the permission of the
Department of Labor it was totally legal
babies and showbiz probably rake in big
bucks right unfortunately not babies
obviously can't talk so they're usually
classified as an under-five a term that
refers to an actor with less than five
lines it's interesting because you could
have a baby who is a recurring character
on a TV show and has a name that the
public can relates you but a lot of
those babies are only getting paid
between you know 200 and 300 dollars a
day so babies don't really make a ton of
money and casting them sounds like kind
of a nightmare are there any other
options
cut to American sniper not all of them
are as fake as this one but plenty of
productions resort to using fake babies
at least for part of the shoot it is
quite common that's you know they'll use
fake babies for the Far Away scenes and
then you know the higher baby when they
need a close-up shot or a face shot and
there are robot babies out there that
look pretty convincing and by convincing
I mean terrifying I never thought I'd
use a Mandy Moore clip in one of my
videos but here we go
they have this one robotic baby it's
weird guys I have like two very
emotional scenes where I'm talking to a
newborn like in the hospital and I like
go to put my hand on the robotic baby
and it's like vibrating and like babies
on screen aren't going away anytime soon
so until producers find a cheap and easy
CGI fix for the baby dilemma it looks
like they'll have to continue to work
within the regulations that are set up
or they'll just cast demonic robot
infants who will destroy us all